[Music]
so so aging infrastructure is a huge
contributor to high cost and actually
poor Public Health in urban areas and
the way that works is the utility
companies they have these power plants
normally in kind of rural areas a little
bit further away from the cities and
then they have these huge transmission
lines that they used to transmit the
electricity to an urban center and you
actually produce a ton of electricity
and kind of lose a pretty significant
percentage of it as it as it as it as it
moves and and so there's already some
costs that everyone is paying for
through kind of older inefficient
infrastructure because of the
inefficiency of the transmission lines
and the the actual age and inefficiency
of the buildings themselves are also
pretty expensive because they waste
energy right so they're inefficient they
over consume electricity per square foot
and so and so that's how aging
infrastructure really contributes to
wasted electricity and wasted
electricity is expensive electricity
I mean we're learning that when you you
you green a building when you do energy
efficiency in a building you're actually
lowering the amount of indoor air
pollution that gets trapped inside the
building and so we're actually reducing
asthma rates as we green each building
and lots of inner-city communities have
lots of pollution the pollution gets
trapped inside the buildings it drives
high asthma rates there's lots of
families go into the emergency room with
chronic asthma so it's this huge public
health crisis it's a huge cost and so we
know that there's all these benefits to
greening buildings you know President
Jimmy Carter put solar panels on the
White House I think in like the 70s
before I was even born and started a
green buildings program called a
weatherization Assistance Program I
think in like 1976 and from then to now
from a policy perspective we've been
trying to figure out how to unlock the
benefits of energy efficiency across
America for decades right because we
know that energy efficiency
reduce energy costs for building owners
it's going to create local jobs it's
gonna reduce our dependence and reliance
on foreign oil and you know it's just
gonna be awesome all around for the
environment the challenges to greening
the buildings is buildings each building
is unique its custom it has its own
profile its own history its own
performance you may have two buildings
that were built at the exact same time
but the history of maintenance is
totally different the owners have been
totally different the ways that the
building are used or totally different
and so you have to learn about the
profile of each building before you can
make an energy efficiency intervention
and the cost of learning the profile of
each building is prohibitive it's too
expensive and so the cost of analyzing
these buildings can be anywhere from
five thousand dollars to five hundred
thousand dollars depending on the size
of the building and it's it's a
difficult thing to ask a building owner
to pay that amount of money to kind of
figure out what's possible to do in
terms of sustainability so that's
problem number one and problem number
two is that banks are not comfortable
providing capital to many of these
buildings as part of thinking through
our CGI you commitment we had to come up
with a range of solutions for the
engineering problem and the financial
problem to help green buildings in
American cities and so what we've had to
do at block power as we worked with
Goldman Sachs and Berkeley is to develop
a structured financial product it's only
reason for existence is to figure out
how to how to analyze buildings and
borrow money in aggregate and a large
enough pool so that we can so that we
can kind of finance the Green Building
interventions that we've made and then a
block power we've developed a set of
technology working with data scientists
and the Internet of Things that allow us
to lower the building analysis cost by
about 95 percent we install sensors we
use cloud computing we have an algorithm
a building science algorithm that we've
built internally a block power that that
takes all of the real-time data that
we're collecting
sensors that we install in the building
we analyze that real-time data we're
able to make recommendations as to what
mix of solar panels high-efficiency
heating systems what ways we can kind of
alter and optimize the performance of
that building's energy system so that it
saves money reduces greenhouse gas we're
able to hire locally to have local
contractors come in and install solar
panels install new heating systems and
boilers so the project's going really
well what's so interesting about these
buildings is that they're really
profitable investments right so if you
can figure it out
you know you can make investments in
some of these buildings that have a 60%
financial return they pay for themselves
within one year and within two years you
start to make a financial return in five
years you've made a 50% return I mean
that's better than buying stocks right
there's just a lot of industry barriers
in terms of engineering analysis
financial analysis construction
implementation that stand in the way of
getting green buildings projects off the
ground so when we think you know five
years from now ten years from now about
how green technology can really increase
efficiency improve infrastructure and
lower costs instead of burning fossil
fuels at a power plant you know 50 miles
away from New York City or from Boston
we can now have local solar panels solar
PV we can have local electric batteries
that store electricity that's generated
by those panels inside the city of
Boston or inside the city of New York
it's the electricity is produced locally
it's transmitted locally it's used
locally we're gonna save a ton of money
is gonna be awesome for the environment
[Music]